luno the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the lay higher pen
show powered by icon plus capital the vc firm
and it is sponsored by block five so i've left
a link somewhere um i think in the description
and in the comments so if you like you can take a
look and they offer a really cool interest rate so
definitely hit on that and um yeah really great
interest rates i think you also get around
um i think about six percent on your
bitcoin so really really interesting there
so joining me today we have a very exciting guest
somebody who i've spoken to a few times and every
single time i speak to him i'm always learning
more it's the founder ceo cio of morgan creek
capital management it is mark yusko mark
great to see you how are you doing today
can you hear me mark
okay maybe you cannot hear me
are we having a technical issue
mark can you hear me
okay guys let me know in the comments if you can
hear me or not um maybe i don't know if it's me
or if it's mark let's have a look i think my
mic seems to be working mark can you hear me
i don't know i don't know if it's me okay guys can
you let me know in the comments if it's me or if
it's mark i don't know mark is frozen hey how's
that yes can you hear me i can i can't oh cool
i don't know what happened i there was a button
i needed to push so i pushed the button and now
we're live oh perfect well welcome to the show how
are you mark i'm doing great doing great thanks
for having me back and uh great to see you yeah
it's a pleasure i'm always learning so much from
you um i think we first spoke back in maybe 2018
or 2019 and we're talking about gold and bitcoin
and you know whether it really can replace it so
we're going to get into all of that but i do want
to start off with um going through some of the
latest headlines because it's been a crazy week
unfortunately things are down china's back in the
news um i want to talk about evergrand i'm sorry
to bring it up i know i know it's not the best
topic everybody is very emotional right now but
i think it's unclear what necessarily happened
and i really like your explanation breaking
down what happened and why there's been
such a spillover into the crypto markets
people often think you know bitcoin is um
not connected and you know not affected by
these things but can you break it down for us
what exactly happened yeah well everything's
interrelated in in in some ways right i mean
nothing is is fully independent of global
capital flows and look the evergrand story
is is interesting in so many ways i mean one
it is uh kind of the epitome of the rags
to riches story that that happened in china
you know you had uh this this process over
over a long time 30 years of basically dragging
you know the population of the us and europe put
together out of abject poverty into middle class
and in order to do that you had to build four
cities the size of philadelphia every year
you just just think about that right i mean just
building four cities the size of philadelphia
every single year and the only way to really do
that was to have shall we say captive companies
and so companies like evergrand were property
developers and they were very well connected and
they had access to a couple things really cheap
land basically grants from from very powerful
people uh they had access to cheap financing and
so the leverage ratios were high and they built
out much of the you know apartment buildings
and complexes and things that that we saw
now it would have been fine i guess if if you stop
there but but as these companies grow they become
involved in other financial services uh and as
as fate would have it we have some cycles in
the market and we had the big uh problem with
the global financial crisis and again making a
long long long story short they used the financial
services infrastructure of china to raise capital
to essentially you know uh booster their balance
sheet and so those products those financial
products were sold through the you know or to
the masses and people thought they were getting
access to great you know long-term investment
property um but as we know and i think you
know i've talked about this in the past but
leverage can never make a bad investment good
right but it can actually make a good investment
bad if you're forced to sell an asset at the wrong
time that can put a lot of pressure on on price
and the problem is once you get the margin call
if you can't go back and raise capital you've gone
to the well too many times which it was the case
here um and maybe you made somebody angry in the
politburo or or maybe the whole movement at the
highest levels of government in china changed
to this idea of you know equilibration of the
classes right let's take some from the top uh and
and push it down the social prosperity thing so
i think all of those factors came into play and
and it wasn't just evergreen right there's a whole
bunch of property developers equity is basically
trending towards zero uh they still have assets
and those assets in many cases are are still
pretty good the reason crypto gets involved is
if you're prone to speculate and um it's
a problem in asia and a lot of gambling
and uh you take macau for example that makes vegas
look like you know a church gathering um so prone
to gambling prone to speculation so you speculate
in a few condos that you lever up then you might
speculate in stocks and lever up because you know
margin debt is is cheap but the real problem was
in crypto right in crypto you bet not five times
leverage or 10 times leverage or 20 times leverage
you get 100 times leverage or 125 times
leverage and again just do the math right
if you're a hundred times leverage a
one percent move wipes out your equity
you're talking about take bitcoin an 80 vol
asset 100 times leverage on an 80 vol asset means
you will lose your bitcoin and i i somebody
call me and say you know they stole my bitcoin
said nope no one stole your bitcoin you made
a dumb decision to lever up a hundred to one
and you lost your bitcoin they didn't steal it now
i will say there is an alternative view which is
if the lender if i'm giving you if i'm giving you
a loan out of the goodness of my heart because i
think you know you're a really good investor and
i want to back you yeah okay however if my goal
is to give you excessive leverage so that i can
actually take the collateral that's a little
sinister and i'm not saying anybody did that but
i'm saying that is another way to look at it that
maybe it wasn't all out of the goodness of their
heart maybe there was some plan to accumulate uh
crypto assets that way so who knows but it's all
interrelated and once leverage starts to unravel
it can get ugly really really fast and i
think that's what we're seeing right now
so people obviously enjoy leveraged trading
particularly in crypto so is there anything people
can do to i guess protect against something like
this i mean either you're very good at spotting
when something's happening like everground and
you know there's way too many too much leverage
too many risks um or you just don't trade with
uh 100x leverage never ever trade anything with
100x i mean that that just pretty much rule
of thumb unless you're a government right
if you're a government or a government-sponsored
entity like an investment bank where you're too
big to fail and no matter what you lose you will
get bailed out and think of a global financial
crisis there were plenty of firms lehman
and others that were 40 80 100 times levered
no one went to jail in fact we bailed them out
it's it's unfathomable but for for the individual
don't don't do it and no matter how easy it
seems uh and even if you win early you will
lose right it's it's kind of like the the winner's
curse you go to a casino and you you place a bet
and you win it's the worst possible thing that
could happen because now you will stay and lose
all your money and then you'll go to the atm
and take out more and try to win it back and
then you lose more the best thing is you you take
a certain amount you play and you have some fun
and you have a couple drinks and you lose it
by the end of the night that's really good
but if you win early you'll think you have
skill and the odds are not in your favor so
levered look investing buying assets below
their value and holding them for the long term
it's a really good thing everybody should
do it trading where you're trying to buy
assets because they're moving and selling
to someone else before they stop moving
tougher some people are good at it not for me some
people get out speculating right buying something
that you have no knowledge of and and doing it
just because it's moving you'll you'll get wrecked
but the worst is just degenerate gambling right
if you're literally playing a game where the odds
are not in your favor i mean literally russian
roulette odds don't be surprised if you know
you shoot yourself in the head so put very well um
i like the use of degenerate gambling particularly
in in this industry we see a lot of it um but
i want to stick on china for the minute because
we've seen another crackdown another band so
in your opinion how serious is this i know
there's that joke that every year um china
bans bitcoin um but obviously not every year
sorry 2017 2021 so it is every four
years whether we need it or not
they're going to be this one's real right now
and why do i say that well in 2013 they kind of
mouthed it they didn't do anything
about it they just kind of said it
there were no teeth and and really it's a very
short correction and we're off to the races 2017
they kind of meant it right i mean they literally
said exchanges you're not welcome here go away and
the prices went down 40 over two weeks uh after
the original announcement in february and they
didn't recover for you know a while and it was it
took you know japan and south korea say bring it
we'll take the exchanges love it we can tax them
we can partner with them and and i think that was
china basically saying look we're playing the
long game and you know here's the problem the
problem with china is china's very misunderstood
everyone thinks they're bad and they're evil
and you know we paint the picture of them
here in the u.s is is like this adversary
china is playing a whole different game i
tweet about this right china playing go we're
arguing about how to set up checkerboard we're
playing an old game using tariffs from the 1930s
they're playing go they're playing a totally
different game there are leagues ahead miles ahead
on the uh almost ready to launch the e-rem and b
the e-rem and b is why they're doing this right
they want to have control of their currency
as as does every other central government and
here's the interesting thing overly indebted
governments have done this since the beginning of
time what do i mean by this meaning use regulation
and use threat of punishment to stop innovation
i mean go go back to the 1930s and in
the depression in the united states it
was criminal it was made a criminal offense
to own gold why well because gold was money
is money gold is money gold is the only asset
in the world that is money meaning it exists
in the absence of a liability everything else
is credit every other currency in the world has
an associated government debt associated with it
so the only money and it's worked for 5 000 years
is gold now bitcoin arguably depending on who you
believe is digital gold i actually ascribe to that
it's the perfect substitute it's a scarce
asset in digital form it's more portable it's
more divisible has all the function doesn't
have an associated liability it's borderless
nation stateless so i think it does take that
place so just like the united states made it
criminal made it illegal for a citizen to own
gold so for 40 years in the united states it
was illegal to own gold now did people own gold
of course they did but they did confiscate gold
from some people they incarcerated some people
and i had this debate with my partners this
morning they're like no chance no chance you
know the united states follows and does this
maybe maybe not and and how do they enforce it
it's not seizable i said well here's the thing
put yourself in this situation you're arrested
you're locked in solitary confinement give
up your private key i'll let you out who does
that who doesn't do that i don't know i might
give up my private key if it means total
loss of liberty or give up my private key
i might i'm not saying i would and now
i'm going to do i understand you know
for saying oh you know you're not going to go
down with the ship i'm like well it depends
so it depends how painful that ship is right how
destructive that is governments have tools to to
enforce i know they can't seize right they
can't hack into the blockchain and take your
your bitcoin but they can make life difficult
and that's what china is doing because china
absolutely positively is playing a different
game they are miles ahead they know exactly
what they want to do to create this belt and road
initiative which is the recreation of the silk
road they are creating trade routes and uh a
community to pull the center of the universe back
to where it was for eighteen hundred last two
thousand years for eighteen hundred of the last
two thousand years the center of the universe was
squarely in china then it moved to europe for 100
years and now it's been in the us for 100 years
it's going back to china there's nothing anybody
can do about it now no one wants to believe that
nobody wants to think that they're capable of it
but they're really smart really highly educated
and they are doing the things that at least
looks to me that you would do if that was your
plan so there's so much going on here because
the way that you know you talk about china
saying that you know they're playing go and
they're well ahead of us um that sort of to me
implies that we should therefore be doing what
china are doing especially if we're if especially
in your opinion if we're going back to china being
the center of everything but that would then imply
that we being the west the uk the usa needs to
do the same and also crack down on cryptocurrency
regulations so that leads me to my next bit
the infrastructure bill and just generally you
know with all these issues with the sec what is
and what isn't a security where are we going
with this people are concerned and should be
concerned you should people should be afraid and
they should they should be legitimately afraid
there are a couple things right one incumbents
have used regulation to beat back disrupters
forever right whether it was the you know buggy
whip manufacturers and the street sweepers at the
turn of century that you know paid the lobbyists
to put up regulation to make it hard for horseless
carriages to come into new york city or whether it
was the train companies lobbying to make it hard
for airlines and airports to get built because
they didn't want people using airlines whether it
was net neutrality around you know telcos whether
it was cable versus terrestrial television whether
it's satellites and trying to limit the numbers
out incumbents will always use regulation because
it can be paid for you know i love americans we're
great right we have this american exceptionalism
and oh all you other countries you're corrupt
china's worked russia's corrupt india is corrupt
what is lobbying that is corruption that's
plain and simple it's corruption i mean i used
my favorite example exxonmobil 2013. they made
40 billion dollars of profit how much should
they have paid in tax 40 tax rate back then
they should have paid 16 billion well they
lobbied 327 million dollars that year highest in
washington and what was their tax bill minus 1.8
billion they actually got a refund that's one of
the great investments of all time you turned 327
million into you know 58 billion in uh i mean and
se into 17 17.8 billion in in a year awesome so
lobbying is is real and what the banks are
doing right now right i believe personal opinion
i think the banks are playing hot
and heavy with the regulators and
putting up hurdles they're not on barriers they're
not you know barbed wire fences with razor wire
but they're hurdles for you know the block fives
and you know one of our biggest investments and
and you know brian armstrong is going at it
with goldman gary um and that's the thing look
jay clayton uh you know i thought he actually did
a really good job he was measured he was pruned
up someone said he was too slow and he didn't
pass the etf but at least we knew the sec was
going to be consistent in their regulation right
now the rhetoric has strengthened and it appears
that maybe the the the roots or the connections to
to the banks because the banks are big losers here
and if you noticed on friday there
were 10 organizations in china that
all said the same thing right we're making this
illegal but who was the spokesperson the bank
of china why because the bank of china has an
over levered banking system that cannot survive
if deposits funnel out of it into things like
alipay and you know crypto and so they cracked
down on ant financial and ollie pay because they
signed 90 billion dollars out of the banking
system says you can't do that anymore now they're
saying we don't want any more to leave into crypto
because that will [ __ ] the banks even more than
they're already crippled and i think the same
things happen in the united states where these
big banks are like wait a second we don't want
our deposits because if i if i put my money in
the bank i get paid zero yeah take that fiat
convert it into crypto deposit it at block fi or
anybody else and get paid why wouldn't i do that
i do do that i think that's awesome but the bank
doesn't like that because now their deposit base
shrinks maybe the loans aren't as good in if the
economy is not going to grow as much and with
demographics as bad as they are we're certainly
not going to grow like we used to because we don't
have any working age population growth and we got
a baby bust so we have all kinds of challenges
for economic growth loan growth banking growth and
if everybody takes a portion of their wealth and
opts out yeah you get to then yeah
absolutely but practically speaking
i'd really like to understand where you see let's
say in the next 10 years this industry with you
know from what i can see regulation is heating up
everything is heating up you know the more um this
this industry expands you know not just
bitcoin but defy and everything that's going on
you know you said we should be worried how are
you no look first they ignore you then they laugh
at you then they fight you then you win okay so
when they were ignoring us you know 2009 to 2015
and you know everybody's partying and having
fun and and developing and it was just a bunch
of nerds and you know just kind of no one
cared it was a little tiny science experiment
2015 like oh wait a minute that's no longer a
science experience ah that's just that's a ponzi
scheme ah hahaha you guys again you just nerd
you don't know anything we're we're finance we're
banks we you know we're in charge 2021 now it's a
fight and 2013 not a fight right that's yeah yeah
whatever we're banning you dumb little game but
you're you know we're not gonna do anything 2017
we're banning you because you're stupid
it's just a stupid little game right this
time we're banning you because you're a threat of
course now name a technology that had to overcome
uh this type of regulatory pressure uh you
know shaming in the in the press you know
the internet even facebook i would just say even
facebook everything i mean they had that day
dynamic technology that went back in the bottle
right that they put the genie back in the bottle
you can't do it there's no way because it's
it's it's a better form of ownership and
what we're talking about here is not just bitcoin
not just ethereum not just money we're basically
talking about value the internet made information
flow two way right just like the printing press
unlocked the lock of power by the church
you know then we had the internet kind of
unlock the power of of government we became a
little bit more democratized around the world
access to information and people could you know
gig economy and lots of good things have come
out of that and basically the media business
and the commerce business got totally disrupted
but remember mom and pop shop owners didn't like
this and they lobbied hard and and the cable tv
companies didn't like this so they lobbied hard
to stop streaming but now everybody streams no
one has cable and not no one but um the same
thing is is true here eventually the technology
wins but this this fight phase will
be unpleasant and it'll be volatile
and it will cause stress and it really depends
how much it escalates right if you think about
you know uh the war over transportation
right the railroads when they were
member i think it was king leopold said why
would anyone pay ever many pence to to go
across europe in an hour when they could
easily take their horse in a day for free
um an hour versus convenience restaurants i don't
know gee yeah yeah it would be more efficient and
and then train tracks but think about you know
they had to go through people's land and they
had to get right away and they had to do eminent
domain and and there were a whole bunch of people
who got really really rich right i mean i live
in north carolina the flagler family basically
owned the east coast of the united states because
they built the railroad from new york to florida
and so that same process is happening now
it's just it's not railroads and it's not
you know terrestrial television or or video
games it is value value over internet protocol
i believe is the most important innovation of
this century it will create untold wealth the
problem is it's not going to be linear
it's actually going to be parabolic
but it's not even going to be smooth it's going
to be choppy and wavy and fits and starts but once
we start into the parabolic phase which hadn't
really started yet it was funny i am i was been
talking and i was saying you know it's it's like
they just finished the national anthem right they
don't even started the game and i was up in new
york at this conference and the guy said no mark
the players haven't even entered the stadium yet
that's how early it is do you have a time frame
like where does the match start look where are we
i've been talking about this for a long time that
yeah we're at this 14-year technological cycle it
has to do with computing power and start with the
mainframe in 54 and the microchip in 68 the
personal computer in 82 and the internet in
96 the mobile net in 2010 and the trust net in
2024. so we're still two years away from that
that's like the beginning of the game then
what happens is four years in you have a crash
so if you go back to 54 there's a crash in
58 you're back 68 there's crashed in 72-73
you go back to 96 there's a crash in 2000.
you go to 2010 there's a crash in 14 15.
so so we've got two years to kind of build
we got to get through this kind of nonsense
of the regulatory hurdles and the the fud
the fear uncertainty and doubt and all the
incumbents not wanting it to happen then we'll
have the aha moment where everybody will say
oh of course it's so clear blockchain technology
is the operating system for the internet of value
oh we call it trustnet okay cool then we'll
all get excited valuations will go parabolic
and then it won't all work and it'll bust and
i use pets.com right pets.com okay can be this
big company they're gonna deliver food using
the internet for your pet it is the epitome
of the failure of the internet chewy.com i get
a box from them every week it's the same company
it's the exact same company same idea same
everything it just took 21 years to mature netflix
almost went bankrupt twice before it went
parabolic all of the big wealth in web 2 was
created after the bust remember when the internet
was going to cease to exist all the naysayers see
i told you that the internet was no more well it
was this because i was probably just born 2000
2001. yeah yeah i mean it was when everybody
said like you know paul krugman famously said
in 96 i think 97. the internet will never
be more important than the fax machine
i really i mean get it that wrong oh my gosh
but and it was labeled a fad and it was labeled
you know something that rot rots the brains of
young people and yeah and there's there's no use
case and i think basically anytime something's
labeled a fad you should buy it by both hands
lock it in a drawer don't look at it because the
problem is if you look at it you'll sell it right
like amazon went down twice 90 and people sold the
only people that bought amazon when it went public
and held to today i said jeff his mom his dad and
his ex-wife that's it everybody else sold because
of the volatility and and the same thing's going
to happen here whether it's d5 and look we haven't
even talked good enough time but we could talk we
could spend all day today and all day tomorrow and
the rest of the week just sitting here talking
to me which would be very pleasant for me but
no we could do it and we wouldn't even scratch
the surface of play to earn of the metaverse
uh well before okay i do want to i do want
to just like talk about this this period of
uncertainty because we have cbdc's which are on
the rise you know you mentioned the digital yuan
um you know the uk are talking about the e-pound
or even brit coin which just makes my ears cry
um so where do you stand on cbdc's i personally
hate them with every part every bone in my body
um that's just me as you should right i
mean yeah they suffer all of the defects
yeah any asset that's created by a monopoly okay
so so you know so they start from a bad place
then on top of that they're basically fiat which
is designed right fiat currency currency that is
not backed by a hard commodity is designed to
steal wealth from the masses and give it to the
rich that's it right the rothschilds invented it
in the 1600s and the you know the bank of england
came a couple couple hundred years later and bank
of spain and and then you know the fed in 1913
central banks were created to steal
the wealth from the masses don't don't
confuse it with you know economic stability
it is theft it is kleptocracy now that said
a central bank digital currency
makes it worse why well right now
they can the central banks through manipulation
of interest rates can push something called
financial repression so in europe or japan you
have negative interest rates right you have to
put your money in the bank and you have to
pay them to hold it so there's no incentive
to save there's an incentive to take your money
out and either invest it in risky assets or
what they really want to do is spend it to create
economic activity why because the people in charge
pale male and stale right have promised
through entitlements which the definition
of an entitlement it's a promise you make
to yourself that you don't fund that you ask
your kids to pay for right my mom believes that
there's a little pot of money in washington dc
called judy's money okay like mom there's no pot
so what do you mean i i paid in all this money
all these years i'm like yeah and it got spent
right now my money goes in for taxes and pays you
but here's the problem when they set it up
in the 1930s there were 17 workers for every
retiree really good system when i reach retirement
age right they'll be two so i was used to say i
lose because my kids would give it to my wife
not me so i had to have a third kid didn't have
the fourth but i had the third so i'm half taken
care of and so the reality is that that process is
is a forced form of compliance but you can
still opt out right i can leave my money in
the bank and i can accept the negative
interest rate or the low interest rate
or the loss of wealth through inflation with a
central bank digital currency holy freaking crap
it's scary what they can do they can program
that if you don't use this
money by the end of the month
if you you because your social score is so low
you can't spend on this fancy car you can't spend
on this piece of art you can't buy this other
digital asset you because we think less of you
can only buy these certain things we can program
the money we can surveil everything you do with
your money right no longer you know can i hand
somebody money or send somebody money gone
all of that is bad and i can probably
get over it except for the fact that
i have a small margin of safety the average
person doesn't have a margin of safety
and that's insane to think that someone works hard
like i have this experience i flew through chicago
to go to a football game this weekend right and
as i'm coming out of the airport i always look at
the price to park for one day at o'hare airport
okay how much to park for one day is like 75
that's two days maybe actually now three
days of minimum wage after tax earnings
to park for one day well they don't park there
they get dropped off but that's not my point
my point is that's insane and now if that person
works really hard to make that 75 if the central
bank can turn on a switch and say boy you know if
you don't spend it at a restaurant or at the gap
i'm sorry it's no longer your money that
is a frightening frightening thought so
for all those reasons i'm i'm in your camp i i
i can't stand the idea of central bank digital
currencies to the core of my being but they're
coming the chinese will be first the russians
will be second we because we're stupid and we're
not doing anything we'll be third or fourth or
fifth well do you think you should be first would
should you be first if you know we don't like it
well it's all evil but if you're gonna be and
you'll be first and evil because here's the
reason that you don't want to be second or third
the dollar today is the evil currency right is
it is the hegemonic world reserve currency because
we cut a deal with saudi in 71 said we'll protect
you if you denominate all transactions globally in
dollars so think about this anyone who challenged
that disappeared saddam hussein i'm going to
price oil in euros gone qaddafi i'm going to
price oil and gold gone anyone who ever threatens
the denomination of petrol transactions in dollars
wiped out okay that's what all the wars are about
all of it now if you are in venezuela and the
dictator comes in gets all his cronies pushes all
the assets to the cronies and then wipes out the
value of the currency so their assets skyrocket
people forget the best performing stock market
in the world the last three years is venezuela
did you want to own any venezuelan stocks no
because you have to live there which actually
is not a bad place but you have to live there
own the venezuelan stocks to get the benefit and
you have to be part of the top but if you're an
average person in venezuela you got wiped
out because the boulevard went down 99.999
so what if you had opted out what did you do you
actually went out in the street and you tried to
buy dollars that was the first thing you did you
tried to buy green pieces of paper now sometimes
they were counterfeit sometimes they're real but
that's what you did well then people said well
hey you could use this thing called dash so let's
use dash has done really well and then we're like
hey you could buy some bitcoin now mostly it's
local bitcoins where you got to meet the guy
or the gal in the alley and you got to swap and
there's a wrench risk and all kinds of bad stuff
and but people did it and they saved some of
their wealth so i think about all of these places
where uh the governments are again intentionally
devaluing their currencies to push the wealth up
to the top of the food chain um all of what we're
all working on now in crypto is to prevent that
and so that's why at the end of the day uh oh
so my point on china china said no no here we'll
give you the e-rem and b just buy the e-rem and
b and we'll honor it and we'll take care of you
so then what happens is the dollar starts to
lose ground as the global war reserve currency
so that's why i think we should have been
there faster because if people wanted to buy
something beside their home currency why not make
it an e-dollar or a fed i wouldn't call it a fed
dollar called an e-dollar but um by the way you
know you know where the dollar the word comes from
well from the netherlands from the rothschilds the
rothschilds set up the first central bank in the
netherlands and theirs was called the dolar so we
stole it because we admired their thievery i guess
and uh now we have dollars i think that the
whole idea of cbdc's absolutely frightened me and
we have that margin like you said that's that's
that safety margin and i think if it wasn't for
bitcoin i would be absolutely petrified like
i always refer to myself as just like awake
and i'm just like watching everything that's
going on um we don't need to i'm not gonna
get political for another time uh i mean we
could do but i won't throw that on you right
we don't even have to get political because it's
all the same all the same but i say this all the
time there's no left there's no right there's
no democrats or republicans or labor or concern
it's in and out and when you're out you do or say
whatever it takes to get in and when you're in
you do or say whatever it takes to stay in so all
this different no they're all the same they're all
after the same thing power and money and
it and it's all about moving it to the top
because we live in a hierarchical world
now the the problem again is technology
has now found a way to invert the pyramid
and they don't like that and that's why
a lot of people are going to do a lot of things
to try to stop this but i remember who said it
to me the first time but think about if you get
lost right do you stop and ask for directions no
especially not where i live in the south because
they say well go to where the old store used to be
take a left and then go to where the oak tree was
and take a right i'm like i don't know where those
are i haven't been here for 20 years so you're
telling me now i look at google maps or apple maps
and i just go and 99 of the time it works but in
code we trust so now you have the ability to have
smart contracts and we have the ability to have
derivative contracts that can't be spoofed by
bankers in london who then get fined and they're
like oh well we build the fines into our business
because it's just part of doing business so yeah
we know we're cheating and we're suppressing
the price of gold but that's what we do in a
smart contract you can't do that and so code
equalizes the top and the bottom and the bottom
get power and jimmy song talks about this so
beautifully he said look if you get a fixed income
right either you know you're on fixed income as a
bond or a pension or if you you know you have
a job and you get paid a wage you're a slave
yes a strong word politically charged but says
you're a slave because you don't control the value
that that creates because they can deflate it away
i mean it's inflated away it says with bitcoin
you become self-sovereign and you become able to
save in a positive way like i i haven't gotten my
bloc fi uh credit card yet because i'm just too
lazy to fill out the stupid i mean because you
know it's like the cobbler's kid have no shoes so
so and and part of his i love my you know american
airlines credit card but i shouldn't because every
time i accumulate all my miles i go to spend them
and they're like oh did we say 20 000 for a ticket
no it's 40. or it's 80. so they devalue my asset
so imagine having an asset like a bitcoin rewards
card where the asset actually increases in value
but what if it doesn't like think about it well
scarce asset rising demand limited supply okay
i i was not a a plus student but i got traded in
economics if supply is fixed and demand rises and
it doesn't have to rise off the charts it just has
to keep rising price faster than inflation it's
got to keep rising yeah so anyway but um okay so
a lot a lot of different things there and i think
what's really interesting is the whole idea of
being a slave to your employer that resonates
with me so much and it's not just about inflation
and it's not just about um you know not being able
to turn around and say well hang on my salary
isn't going as fast as inflation is going
um it's also just about like the whole idea of
trading time for dollars and you know just just
taking ownership of your time like the whole idea
of sovereignty i'm trying to um bring that ethos
into my life in general not just with money but
just with everything like i want to be sovereign
over my time over everything that i do um and i
think that's also what i love about crypto and
bitcoin that it does it doesn't just teach you
about money it teaches you once you you grasp
the concept of money and sovereignty and autonomy
it then changes your opinion on everything and the
way you look at everything a hundred percent
and i talk about something everything we do
is about converting energy to value yes
right you and i we got up this morning
we put some fuel in our body and we go about
our day trying to convert energy into value
and you know bitcoin is one of those perfect
vehicles for turning energy into value
and it's a perfect store of that value
because it can't be inflated away by by fiat
and there are a lot of ways you can create
value in the world i mean you could make
stuff right assemble widgets you could entertain
others you could you know create new algorithms
uh that could that create value in the
future you could innovate new technologies
um you could make an old technology new again
i mean people forget all the time they're like
oh elon musk invented the electric car no it
didn't the largest car company in america in 1903
was the american electric vehicle company right
and henry ford put him out of business because he
wanted people to buy his cars that ran on kerosene
or or gasoline which is an effluent of kerosene
that john d rockefeller wanted to sell rather
than flush down the river and have the river
catch on fire and so you know that was dormant
technology for the better part of a hundred years
before they said oh we should have
vehicles where we don't make the power
on site right internal combustion engine means
every car is its own power plant how about if we
have a combined power plant and then
we distribute the energy and store it
interesting concept but again not new right
there's a car in the basement of dartmouth
engineering school that went 46 miles to
the charge back in 1903. it's pretty cool
it is and i i do want to move on just a little
bit um and i want to talk about investments
and really just spotting that investment
because like you said i guess actually it's
not really moving on that much because you know
you said not everything new is necessarily new
right like the electric car so given that right
now we are still so early as everybody likes to
say we have you know um nfts booming how are you
spotting a good investment because i understand
that's what you said you know that is where true
wealth is is built from being super early the the
greatest wealth comes from investing in something
you believe in before others even understand it
yeah how do you believe in it well you have to
be exposed to it okay so how do you get exposed
to to new ideas hang out with really smart
people and and make it a point to you know
look for new ideas you know i i say all the time
i have the greatest job in the world i get paid
to talk to the smartest people in the world
right that's my job right i supposed to go around
and talk to people in hedge funds and private
equity and venture capital and entrepreneurs and
and some of these people are just really really
really incredible and if you can't pick up a thing
or two then you know you're just fast asleep
so one is just hang out with the right people
yeah i understand when i tell young people
you know think of the four people you spend
the most time with that's who you'll
become choose wisely so we should all
constantly be thinking about who we want to hang
out with and who we want to spend our time with
but but in terms of spotting investment ideas
very few almost zero are oh i woke up one day
with this great idea i mean a lot of people think
they do that not very many actually do mostly it's
uh a friend of a friend of a friend introducing
me to somebody and they tell me something that
is interesting so uh you know how did we invest
in infrastructure for the internet back in the 90s
i was working at the university uh we went out to
california for two weeks we hung out interviewing
actually we weren't interviewing we were begging
to get in to kleiner perkins sequoia excel all
these firms that even then were popular but they
weren't the brand names that no one can get into
so you could you could get access and in talking
to those those guys and gals you you heard stories
about just amazing innovation but to be honest
right when when they told us about this company
you know called google and the search engine right
wait there are 20 search engines why do we need 21
right there was alta vista there was web
crawler they said no no you don't understand
those do search the wrong way we've invented a
new way to do search and and look like i was i
was one week old okay a week ago i actually
learned that you know there are 1.7 billion
websites on the planet okay 1.7 billion websites
7 billion websites ish are owned by google
and everybody doesn't surprise me well here's
here's why every time you type in a question or
i type a question into google they create a new
website unless that question's already been asked
then they just send you to that website so
boom mind blown indexation they don't search
the entire web think about searching the entire
web for some stupid question i ask about you
know italian's football or something okay no it
just sends me to the same question that someone's
already asked and i get the instantaneous answer
so that innovation led to incredible wealth
creation i you know i always say there should
be a quad at notre dame called the google quad
or you know when when uh we saw uh the opportunity
in the mobile net to invest in e-commerce and we
invested in alibaba and we invested in vip shop
and and we invested in in the companies that were
helping these companies do the the infrastructure
the fulfillment services you know the machines
and again it wasn't that we were geniuses it
was that we heard these incredible entrepreneurs
and here was the funny part webb vann which was a
total failure in 2000 right smartest guy head of
arthur anderson uh leaves starts this company huge
backing i think like seven seven hundred i mean it
was some crazy number and they were gonna deliver
stuff to people using the internet and it totally
created total loss doordash and and ubereats are
the same thing we just needed broadband we needed
more delivery we needed gps you know how did
we get gps this is an awesome story right
so gps was this system for the government right
and they built it literally using eminent domain
on a piece of spectrum that was
owned by this big hedge fund uh guy
and they were going to create this fourth network
and att and verizon and t-mobile there was going
to be this fourth one that was going to compete
and we had invested in it and the two big ones
through lobbying corruption basically said we
don't want them to compete with us so here's what
here we say go to them and say you know that that
uh gps system your new network is interfering and
that's a national defense risk of course well
wait a minute is my property you built a garage
on my property and now you're telling me that
my property interferes with your enterprise
sounds about right about how it happened and and
so get went bankrupt and but we needed that gps
system so they can track
us all the time on these um
and so all of it comes together to say so how
do you how do you pick a good investment uh one
talk to lots and lots and lots of people and
listen to lots and lots of crazy ideas um
but i also say that in much of it is just
pattern recognition you know if you've heard
one story about a 50 chance getting it right
until you think and then your odds go down if
you've heard 10 stories actually got a little
better odds because you can hear the bad ones
because they're really easy i would say i know
in five minutes i'll never invest with somebody
my five years sometimes to figure in five minutes
though what's the red flag in five minutes oh it's
just look there's so many right i mean there's the
no jerk rule i have more fanciful term for that
but there's the no jerk rule i mean just people
who are arrogant people who are pig-headed people
who aren't courteous i mean one of my big things
is right how do you treat the other people around
you i mean people who don't treat their peers and
you know and subordinates well no time um you know
there's things that are fanciful that just don't
sound right they sound too big and too grand
but then there's the stuff we just you just
listen well it's the first time i met zach
and flory at block fight right it was just easy
i mean she's a genius he's an amazing leader
i mean together they're magic and and
part of it is just you've seen it before
right and you know having white hair proves i've
been around long enough because it is true that
old saying that which doesn't kill you makes you
stronger all the losses make you a better investor
right all the times you made a mistake that
you thought something was going to be great
and um i'm a big believer also in and now it's
really popular and and i'm not saying i was
early i again it wasn't my idea i read in business
school this paper by paul romer and paul romer won
the nobel prize three years ago for something
called the law of increasing returns and i read
this paper as part of my you know class and i but
it just it struck me it just it just hit me what
he said is it's not the best technology that wins
it's the technology that gets critical mass first
and so for the rest of my career which that's
luck right why did i read that paper luck total
luck could have blown that assignment offer like i
did many other assignments but i actually read it
and it and it just hit me that the network effect
was real and that yes it was this getting to
critical mass and you know i remember in in 2000
when it was 17 right when we were starting morgan
creek digital you know and i was getting that was
my hashtag big really big you know blockchain is
big really big bitcoins big really big people
like you're an idiot it's a ponzi scheme and
why do you believe in this and and i said
look it it it is we've seen this movie before
and the miracle was not whether bitcoin
would go from a thousand dollars back then
to four thousand dollars or forty thousand
dollars or four hundred thousand dollars
which was my price target at the time
yes but it was that it went from 0.004
to 1 that was the miracle right it should have
died it should have been a science experiment
that failed but it didn't and so then you
have to do the work and when you do the work
and you realize this is innovation writ large and
eric schmidt summed it up better than anybody else
as only eric schmidt can smart guy from google
he said look what satoshi nakamoto whoever he
she they are did is not that they create a bitcoin
okay that that's big but that's not the big thing
the big thing is that he she they created a
way to create scarce assets in a digital world
because in the analog world scarcity is easy i do
a painting there's only one it is scarce yes if i
take a a picture of that and i put it into a jpeg
i can copy paste a million times it's not scarce
anymore the electronic world had very difficult
time with scarcity yeah in the digital world now
with nfts i know chris dixon's i'm not going to
steal his thunder because he he did it i didn't
but he did this thread a week ago about why nfts
are so much bigger than anyone understands because
it's not about crappy art or good art depending
on your view of art it's not about crypto punks or
you know rare pepsi it's it's about digital
scarcity yeah and that there will be
tokens okay whether non-fungible or whatever
just tokens there will be tokens someday
orders of magnitude more than websites and
websites make the internet so now we're
gonna have orders of magnitude more tokens so we
can exchange anything a value every stock every
bond every currency every commodity a piece of
art a piece of real estate every case of wine
that you know that that silly piece
of art behind me right that that
my car outside everything will be tokenized and
it will live outside borders outside nation states
that's what scares the nation states
that's what scares the governments that's
what scares the banks because now you and i
can exchange value in a two-way transaction
without any intermediary without any counterparty
risk without any fees now there will be fees there
will be fees like right now i can send you bitcoin
across lightning for zero that's the wrong number
and and we own a little piece of that company and
we're really excited uh with strike but with the
bitcoin tipping i mean the twitter tipping
and all that but zero's the wrong number
right there has to be some fee for executing
these transactions but right now it's about growth
it's about accumulation and back to paul romer
what paul romer said is there's a reason that
the technology that gets the biggest network
effect wins it's because it becomes unassailable
and people say oh but what about myspace and and
facebook michael yes now it's even better that was
in a closed source world in an open source world
it's over because in the closed source world i
actually could invent something better right the
technology of facebook was superior to myspace
incrementally but it was better now if you are
the main coder for the bitcoin blockchain and
i want to add something incremental you hit
copy paste and you're just as good or better
so the open source world coupled with the
metcalf's law growth you know once something
becomes the leader it becomes unassailable
and the compounding effect of these markets
is why i do believe this is the greatest wealth
creation opportunity i'll see in my lifetime
i think it's truly incredible everything is
just going digital um you answered my next
question i really wanted to hear your thought on
nfts but yeah you've definitely answered that um
which means you've answered my question on your
thoughts on ethereum um and everything else but
just finally then all go on did you did you know
i think ethereum is an amazing toolkit i think it
has some limitations and of course i think there
are other layer ones that are you know trying to
to compete and ultimately i don't think we need
to know right now if you go back to the internet
there were 80 protocols there's tcpip
and there was a whole bunch of others
today we have five right we got tcp we got ftp we
had http we got smtp and we got www dot that ties
everything together yeah in your future no i can
see a world where bitcoin's the base layer where
filecoin does what ftp does maybe maybe
it's solana maybe it's polka dot that is
two layers and then ethereum is the www dot never
says oh but it doesn't scale and it's you know
look not today tomorrow good technology innovators
will innovate and they will solve the problems or
someone else will solve something else and it will
gain critical mass and you know and we'll have
other solutions but i think at least right now
it appears that the btc and ethr are the leaders
and i look at one as a base layer and a use case
as digital gold i look at the other as a tool
kit on which other things will be built and the
benefit of that is unlike a store of value where
the increase in value is determined by usage the
more users and a fixed supply the higher the value
here we have a model where we can share right
actually infinity grossed more than fortnight
in the last 12 months it's unbelievable and part
of it's owned by the user community that's awesome
and that model will be replicated over and over
again and that there will be we invested in uber
lyft grab hola quadi which became one of them
we did every ride-sharing company on the planet
because we thought it was amazing yeah all of
those will be displaced by decentralized versions
because there's no reason that when i got a ride
to the airport the other day up in chicago that 30
of that money went to a centralized organization
just for writing code years ago no reason for that
now will they decentralize themselves
probably not so somebody else will probably
create it but the hard part is replicating the
network effect so we'll see yeah i think it's
essential to have an open mind about all the
different protocols that are being built in the
moment um for me bitcoin is king i do believe will
always be king especially when it comes to being
a sort of value obviously as we've spoken about um
but i'm excited you know who knows it's impossible
to know you know what's coming next um but just
finally um i want to ask you given bitcoin has
you know is down at 42k today where are we at in
this cycle um a lot of people um are calling for
new all-time highs i know jason williams is
calling for an all-time high the end of october
he loves the end of october so where do you stand
on this or are we heading into a bear market
and pop and i had a little debate about this this
morning okay um and look i i hope they're right
okay i do caveat that with hope is not
an investment strategy it's actually a
four-letter word so hopefully not a
good thing to hang your hat on and
and jason has very good reasons for why he thinks
that's gonna happen uh as does pomp um look i
i believe that predicting the future is impossible
to your point and then like soros said you should
think in scenarios not in single points so i
believe the range of outcomes this year looks
actually pretty bell curved normally i would
say the distribution of outcomes in in bitcoin
is skewed to the right right it's not a perfect
bell curve it's it's skewed to the right and it's
heteroscedastic meaning that there's you know more
right tail wrist and left toe risk okay that said
um i think right now i think we're pretty
bell-shaped i think there is a low probability
that we bust through the 64 000 and
and make trip and make quad digit
and and the reason i believe that's a low
probability is i i unfortunately have probably
convinced myself that um if you go back in
time and you say oh well this is just a four
year cycle that has to repeat okay totally
logical yes with one flaw uh in 2009 cycle
repeated john 13 cycle repeated 2017 cycle
repeated um so why is it different this time
2009 13 and 17 everyone wasn't looking at
the same model right number nine there were
no models 2013 there were no models 2017 there
was the one parabolic trav model i don't think
he actually even made it some other guy made it
but it basically showed the metcalf's law parabola
and then um cane island crypto uh did his version
tim peterson did his version there was a lower
trajectory because he had a different decay
rate and his actually been much more accurate so
then uh 100 100 trillion came along and love him
love his work but here's the problem is everyone
was looking at that model and everyone including
myself was convinced that on july 15 of this year
we were going to hit a hundred thousand and then
we were likely going to have that parabolic blow
off that you know max keiser and and jason and
all the others were saying we're going to 200
or 220 or 250. totally logical it's exactly what
happened in 2017. totally logical we hit 100 i
mean we hit the 10k six days after the model said
and within five weeks we were double that because
that's when the speculators come in and the greed
pushes price above value then we crashed because
we didn't have any way to custody it right and
we had to build out the custody and we had to
get the institutions and so we went all the way
down to six and then all the way down to three
and so here we are we hit 64. i unfortunately
believe that whether it was michael bury
or someone else like him i might even posit that
elon himself might have been short who knows
but um somebody got short and they got short
in size and they triggered what we're talking
about at the beginning of this there were way
too many people with a hundred times leverage
1.7 million liquidated liquidated and boom
we're down 55 percent then liquidation stop
some institutions come in and buy again
whether that was elon buying or others
but there were two big accounts 1.7 billion
each buying um back in july and were up 50
from that bottom back to the low 40s and so
everybody's like oh we're back in the bull market
possible the problem is it's possible and
i'm not saying likely but it's possible that
this cycle has been truncated because too many
people were looking at the uh stock to flow model
and that the rollover this time was the top and
then that means we're in an 18-month bear pattern
until the next and that doesn't mean we have to
go to 94 it just means we could be stuck here the
thing i'm most concerned about and again it's not
it's not a big concern i don't lose sleep over it
but i am concerned about it that no one that i
know and i know a decent number of people no one
i know saw november october november uh 2018 six
to three no one i mean i'm sure somebody out there
saying i saw it i saw them like i don't believe
it um no one i know saw it and why did that happen
supply and demand i mean you only get the
parabolic moves when people are buying on margin
there aren't enough new owners in size and pomp
has some very compelling stuff that will put
together on the number of new addresses on the
chain that came in as of july this year very
compelling but the dollars aren't big and
so until we and and here's the problem as
i see it you just had the three largest uh
exchanges in the world basically just told
we're gonna shut you down now they didn't
exactly say it that way but they basically
said even if you try to operate outside china and
come get chinese money we're coming after you so
look finance or binance depending on how you
pronounce it uh i never heard anything i say
finance i just say binance and i like that's
interesting it's like insurance and insurance
but and then wobe and ftx and fgx is moving to the
u.s and they're doing us but but there's still a
lot of it's china and still 20 of volumes and
whether that dries up so if if that is shrinking
show me the new money that's entering at
a pace that can cause a parabolic move
i hope it's there i would love to see it and
i'm working hard every day to try to convince
institutions pension funds endowments wealthy
individuals that they should get off zero
but it's still it's still tough so that's
a long answer leo that yeah it's okay i
i don't want to be the boo bird right
i don't want to be the guy who says oh
you know we're in for a bear market
but i think we're stuck right now and
if we get incremental buying power
um i do think that the free float
small enough that we could and that's why i
say there's there's a small probability that we
could have that blow off two to six or to nine
digits but we're six digits we need that yeah
we need that new money basically we need a lot of
new money it's in your money and and look we need
the next billion right i did i participated in
this thing called the coins podcast uh which is an
awesome thing and the guys did such a great job
putting it together when i say guys i mean guys
and gals um but uh because it was guys and gals
and they did such a great job so well produced
so high quality all the you know the ogs are
there and and you know i got to be there because
you know i'm i'm friendly with with patrick and
it's awesome but it's for the next billion right
we need to get the next billion and i'll leave
you with this it's so funny so i got asked to
speak the google investment club a number of years
ago and uh google value investment club actually
and uh so i go we're walking around the campus
with this group of of you know very smart you
know guys and they make so much money that they
want to invest it in value instead of putting
it all in google and i said so so how many people
are on the campus the one guy says oh you know 25
000. and the other guy says are you kidding
me there's 40 000. i said so within 15 000
people you know how many people are on this little
campus which is not little and i think that's the
problem of of how many users are there in bitcoin
right are there 100 100 million or 200 million
we know within 50 or 100 million how many there
are we don't know exactly so getting the next
billion is really really important and that
takes you know tom and gisele saying are you in
right that's awesome and it takes people
seeing ads in the mainstream media and it
it takes something emerging like godaddy
did for the internet it makes me know a
website why did i do a website so um all those
things are important but ultimately it goes to
uh need right when people need to opt out yeah no
i'm actually surprised there aren't more users in
europe quite honestly with negative interest
i know i would think everyone and their sister
would be you know opting out for at least a
portion uh and taking money out of the banks
of course then they'd be exacerbating the problem
that the banks would fight back against but
uh we are aware better than better than negative
interest rates yeah i'm with you i think um need
is actually a really important point and that
um in my opinion is sort of the silver lining
in the last 18 months that we've had you know
whether it's um inflation with more money printing
um whether it's um vaccine passports and all
these things you know which really just come down
to more control greater control um crypto for me
bitcoin whatever you want to call it um is kind of
just like that lifeboat and um so many people have
been red peeled and orange peeled and all these
sorts of fun colors um in the last 18 months so
yeah i think you know um need will be will be that
will be the case we see that in africa and latin
america and so on um you know the cool part is
it's inevitable yeah uh it will take
longer than we all think or want
but it's inevitable because it is superior
technology it is solving basic human needs
and and the talent right two things to do in
investing follow the money follow the talent
and the talent migration into this space
is like nothing i've ever seen and i've
been around a long time and i've seen lots of
talent migrations different levels the internet
was by far the biggest best incredible
this is bigger and you know people who
you just can't believe are leaving that their
traditional jobs their traditional world
and uh you just remind one last story and
i'll let you go no go for it yeah i just did
gas the digital asset summit here up in new
york uh last week or two weeks ago i guess
and um two years ago was the last time we did
it because the coveted lockdowns the nonsense
and it was the last you know live
event i did in november of 19 and
uh i remember being up on stage doing the closing
keynote and and i finished and you know i was
doing my ra rod this is you know what you should
do and this young guy comes up and says hey
would you call my mom like what he says well
you were up there saying that you know this is
the greatest talent migration and that we're smart
for going into this and my mom thinks i'm an idiot
i left this big law firm and and it's amazing
and i said yeah let's call your mom so we called
his mom and said no your son is not an idiot he's
really smart and uh this is big really big and and
uh you know i need to find out who it was and
and meet him and have a beer and and see how
he's doing but um i'm sure he's doing well and
it it is it is one of those things where uh
i love the people that i hang out with i
love doing stuff like this with you and
and the energy the enthusiasm the uh the desire to
to to make the world a better place right yeah you
know you hear jimmy speak and you're like man i'm
gonna go save the world i you know i don't wanna
buy bitcoin i wanna i wanna yeah and there's so
many people and if we can make some money along
the way great that's good too but there's so many
other really important things like reversing the
wealth and income inequality problem that we
have around the world like raising more people
out of poverty like my personal pet peeve how
can we have a weight loss industry in the united
states where we spend 20 billion dollars a year
and 10 million kids go to bed hungry every night
that's unacceptable that's absolutely unacceptable
insane how can that be that's because people
don't spend time on it and they think it's
okay and uh it's not okay and there are
lots of things that we can do um taking many
of these technologies that we're all working on
to make those things better and there are people
working on it and don't and i love and admire all
those and we support them with our foundation and
things like that but so much of this fight and i
said this is the fight right first they ignore us
then they laughed at us now they're gonna fight us
and it's funny i saw a clip of myself um from
2018 right after i formed morgan creek digital
i was on one of the morning shows with maria
i think and she said so you know you've spent
all this time in the traditional world and you
know what are you going to do now i'm like well
it's so funny because i was all suited up and i
looked really good i'm like man i look like crap
now i don't wear a suit i wear this silly suit
suits are dead but i was looking pretty sharp and
uh and uh i had my orange tie on for bitcoin and i
said look i'm gonna spend the next two decades uh
tokenizing the world nice and i was like wow
and i looked back and i and i had tweeted it
out and hashtagged it and and and look that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna tokenize the world and
every asset in the world is gonna be tokenized all
of it is gonna drive this trust net this internet
of value and is gonna change everything and it's
cool it is cool um i think it's incredible that as
things get harder in this world and
authoritarianism comes strong we have an
option to opt out we have um an option to um and
a method to make the world a better place that's
one of the reasons why uh what really drew me um
to this industry was not so much bitcoin at first
but it was much like blockchain technology and
you know banking the unbanked i don't know that
really excited me that's always really excited me
so 40 of the adults in the world don't have a bank
account two-thirds of them have a mobile phone
and all of them can be they can be self-sovereign
and look there are tons of amazing stories
in my my latest one i've been telling which
i think is just totally cool is uh these migrant
farmers in southeast asia they were getting paid
literally like a dollar a day to do really hard
work uh basically started doing axi infinity and
bought some axes and started breeding the axes
and they're now selling them they're making
now tens of thousands of dollars a year instead of
a dollar a day and everybody says oh that's just
such a waste of time like are you kidding me it
is awesome it is an awesome example of technology
making people's lives better and those people
will become better citizens and and i go back
to there was a time in the united states where
every african-american doctor or lawyer in america
was the son or daughter of a pullman porter
pullman porters were indentured servants they were
owned by the railroad okay don't like to talk we
don't always talk about that right they were owned
these people were owned by the road but they all
saved up and made better lives for the kids send
them to school got them educated and eventually
we had an african-american president and that is
awesome right and that's what's happening here is
we're seeing this technology impact real people's
lives around the world and some might say well
what good is an axie well my son and i have had
a lot of fun playing video games together and we
bond over it and you know we teach i teach them
about business and i don't know i i see value in
it and i think that person's life now is better
and from that project maybe they graduate to an
up maybe actually they go back to school and learn
how to code and then maybe they get a you know
job and maybe they build the next scaling solution
who knows um maybe that's a little fanciful but
it's not impossible so yeah no i'm with you um
but mark i want to thank you so much it's always
so fascinating um to speak with you we've gone
through so many topics more than i'd expected
so it's really amazing so i really appreciate
it thank you so much for coming on now great
to be with you later we'll talk to you soon all
right guys and don't forget to tune in next week
for another brilliant guest we'll see you then